I was that kid that you know I'd crawl
out of the attic and I'd be on the roof
and my neighbors would see me on the
roof and I was about four years old
because I like I like looking at the sky
in the clouds and the stars and stuff
and they'd call my mother and she'd be
like your son is on the roof and to me
it was just normal but she she's such a
beautiful soul that she just basically
just asked me to think about what I
wanted to do with my life you know she
never stopped me from doing anything it
was very encouraging wow but wow she
never stopped me I showed her when I was
on the a400 the side of the airplane and
Rogue nation and
she's like honey is it
[Laughter]
I said yes ma'am it is she goes oh oh
Lord yeah I'm so glad you didn't tell me
about that one
there's no need to know